LUKMAN RAMSEY: Looking
for ideas about how
to scale your machine learning,
training, and prediction?
Well, you've come
to the right place.
With over 500
sessions at Next 2018,
it's understandable that you
couldn't get to them all.
So if you didn't see
ML in Production--
Architecting for
Scale, then stay tuned
because here's the rewind.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
When it comes to
machine learning,
there's toy ML
and production ML.
Both are very important, though
different types of problems
to solve for.
And when we say scale,
as it pertains to machine
learning it not only means
the usual "you require
additional servers"
but also being
able to scale up to more
training data or bigger models
and not having reduced
availability and response time
when prediction load increases.
On the training side of
things, you should definitely
be using the tf.data API.
And if you're using it
in a distributed system,
there are a couple
of handy arguments
to add to some of
your method calls
that will dramatically improve
the speed with which you
can read in data.
And this becomes
especially important
when it comes time
to use accelerators
like GPUs and TPUs.
One additional area
that may be worth
exploring if you want to have
just a little more control
of your infrastructure
is Kubeflow
which helps you run
TensorFlow on Kubernetes,
though it's not limited
to just TensorFlow.
In this library, it tries to
address some of the challenges
around composability,
portability, and scalability
that are faced when
building larger ML systems.
Turning now to the
production side of things,
there are a number
of optimizations
that are worth exploring.
The Graph Transform
Tool and TF Lite
allow you to optimize your
model for serving speed,
and there is even
a guide for how
to properly optimize the
batching of your prediction
calls.
So that's handy.
And finally, check out
TensorRT, a library
that allows you to take full
advantage of the Tensor Cores
in NVidia's V100 GPU.
This library was developed in
conjunction with the TensorFlow
team here at Google.
So when it comes to scaling
up machine learning,
there is a lot of options to
navigate and choices to weigh.
So be sure to check
out the full talk
if you've got some
ML scaling challenges
that you are working on.
Thanks for watching
this Cloud Rewind.
And if you like the
video, give a thumbs up.
I've included a link to the full
talk in the description below.
And don't forget to subscribe
for more great content,
and I'll see you
on the next Rewind.
[MUSIC PLAYING]